one. Good afternoon. It's Mike here. Um
get started in a second. Just making
sure everything uh
is recording and and sound is good.
Looks uh
looks like we're good to go. All right.
So, um hey again, you know, thanks for
coming out for this uh little workshop
on the order flows flows tip indicator
for Ninja Trader 8. It's,
you know, it's a new indicator. It was
actually one that we weren't really
planning on releasing, but then I showed
a few traders like, "Hey, you know what?
you got to get that out there for for
other traders. So,
um I sort of rushed to get it out uh
towards the end of the year
um while I was busy traveling just
trying to get it all uh up and and
prepared for everyone.
And you know, it's the feedback has been
good. So, you know, I'm glad that
everyone is getting a use out of it.
But, you know, for those of you that
aren't familiar with it yet, that's what
this uh presentation is for. Um so again
you know welcome to the orderflows flows
tips workshop where we'll be discussing
the orderflows flows tip uh indicator.
You know most traders don't lose because
their idea is horrible. You know their
trade idea they lose because they're
late to the shift in the order flow
right they're trading a single time
frame in a multi-time frame game. You
know we we all like to look at our own
types of charts. you know, whether
they're a minute-based chart, whether
they're a Reno chart, whether it's
rangebased chart,
and that's all well and good, but you
know, we're not trading against traders
that look at those charts. We're we're
trading a chart that makes puts the
market in the most sense to us as
traders, but you know, the the big
traders, guys that move the market,
they're looking at um they have sort of
a broader stroke of the market. Okay?
Okay. And that's why I talk about
multi-time frame game is um you know
sort of a longer time frame
view of the order flow. Um you know
traders lose because they're guessing
from candles and noisy footprint numbers
instead of seeing who actually owns the
bar. You know who's really in control.
Um you know because at the end of the
day trading is between buyers and
sellers. You know one person is going to
uh beat the other person.
You know how it goes right as a trader.
You think you have a great trade. You
enter right as the move runs out of
fuel, right? Your stops get tagged to
the tick. We've all seen that where we
get stopped out literally to the tick
and the market rips in your original
direction, right? You felt something
maybe in the order flow, but you can't
see it clearly enough to act with
confidence. That's just not psychology.
That's an information problem, right?
It's not a problem with you as a trader
per se with your um your mindset. It's
how you're dealing with the information.
Okay, you're trying to make real-time
decisions about a live auction using
tools that show you only a blurred
vision version rather of the battle
between aggressive and passive traders,
right? And it's a constant fight, right,
between these aggressive traders, you
know, they're they're lifting the
offers, they're hitting the bids,
passive traders are absorbing them, all
right, leaning on a level or stepping
back. You know, it's sometimes it's it's
when those passive traders, you know, we
always talk about the aggressive traders
are the ones that move the market. Well,
they are, but it's the passive traders
that support the market, offer
resistance, and when they back off,
what's left to stop the market? You
know, every bar is a negotiation between
those two traders, between the passive
and and aggressive traders.
Now, the most important moments for us
as traders are the tipping points,
right? where aggressive buyers finally
overwhelm passive sellers at a level
where aggressive sellers suddenly run
into a wall of passive buying. You know,
where neither side has a real edge,
market is just chopping, right? These
tipping points almost never show up
cleanly in a traditional chart. And even
on a footprint, you can easily get lost
in the numbers. So, flows tip is an
orderflow tipping point detector, right?
Hence the name flows tips, right?
because it it's designed to answer one
question in every bar right now in this
bar. Who is actually in control? Buyers,
sellers,
or nobody? You know, sometime, you know,
sometimes no one's in control. The
market's just doing what the market
does, which is facilitate trade.
So, here's how the flow tips indicator
approaches that. It looks inside each
bar at where meaningful volume trades.
It evaluates how that volume trades. Are
buyers lifting offers or selling hitting
bids? Reads the behavior within the
current context. Are we driving, you
know, moving in a direction? Um
rotating, or is it balanced? Is market
getting squeezed? Are traders fading? It
runs all that through a proprietary
algorithm to flag control shifts the
moments when the auction is tipping
quote unquote tipping from one side to
the other. You don't see the math
involved, you know, in the footprint.
You don't got to analyze the footprint
itself. I mean, you could run
the flow tips on a footprint chart, but
you don't need to. You can run a regular
bar chart. And what you're going to see
instead of seeing a footprint with all
the numbers is you're going to see a
clear visual representation of who owns
the bar and whether that control is
strengthening, weakening, or flipping.
So, just really quick, let's pull up a
chart here.
Okay, this is um what do we got here?
Euro currency with flows tips, right?
And
Let's go here. Get this on. So, you can
see bullish signal, bullish signal,
bullish signal on the way up. Bearish
signal, you know, on the way down,
right? I mean, this is I'm going to get
into the indicator settings in a moment,
but I just wanted to show you, right,
how it's it's reading what's the trading
that's actually taking place in the bar,
you know, off these settings. Where are
we here? You know, there's a tips level,
swing filter. This is just using sort of
the defaults with the tips level at the
lowest level, momentum strength, but
I'll talk about the settings a little
bit later. Okay, but this gives you an
idea. You know, it's it's measuring, you
know, giving a firing off a bullish
signal here, another one here, another
one here, right? Another one here. Then
it sort of hits its apex up here,
and it starts selling off. And as it
starts selling off, you get the bearish
signal, right? and it moves back down.
All right, so let's walk you through a
few examples so you can see how this
actually works. So again, these are the
settings. Obviously, the license token
when you get a license
multi-time frame analysis. This is what
I was referring to earlier
talking about the longer the higher time
frame. Okay, so you could set, you know,
five minutes and what that does is it
will analyze a five minute order flow
plotted on your one minute chart or your
your rangebased chart or your volume
based chart or your Rencobased chart.
Okay? So you most indicators just
analyze a chart that's on your screen.
So you're not taking into account um
sort of a a higher time frame. People
say, "Well, 5 minutes isn't much of a
higher time frame." Well, in order flow
it is, okay, because you know, order
flow gets stale um pretty quick. But
when you're looking at sort of a higher
time frame, again, you know, I'm not
going to say you got to look at a 4hour
order flow. I think that that's not very
useful. But, you know, keep it within,
you know, 5 10 15 minutes. When you see
the aggregation of the order flow come
in, it can give you some nice powerful
signals. Tips levels one through six,
one being the lowest, six being the
highest. I'll talk about that later. and
a little bit of momentum strength one is
the minimum. Okay,
so this is bonds today or sorry, ultra
bonds today using that settings that I
just showed you, right? The five minute
setting with tips level at one, momentum
strength at one,
right? Right. So, it's catching this
major move up, more move up here, move
down, little move up sideways, nice
right before this big drop at 9:00 where
it went from, you know, basically 03
down to 24 and then back up from, you
know, 28 all the way back up to, you
know, 05, 06, 07, 08. It's a 10-point
move here, 10-point move back up
simply by looking at a slightly higher
time frame, five minute analysis as
opposed to, you know, this is a one
minute chart.
This is another example. This is Euro
currency. Now, this is actual underlying
chart. Chart zero means it's it's the
basic chart with the same settings. One
tips level, one momentum strength. Okay,
I showed you a chart from earlier just
now. This is from even earlier today.
Move back down, move back up, right?
Bullish bar right here. See how the
volume is being distributed. You do got
one buying a balance, one selling a
balance. Point control somewhere in the
middle. Starts working its way back up.
Finds its tipping point up here.
Right here you got some nice bearish
order flow. We got a couple zero prints,
got a line point of control, some buying
imbalances in these red bars, and the
market moves back down. So, you catch
this move up, the move back down, back
and forth.
Now,
before I get into some other examples, I
just want to run through some of these
settings really quick. So, the
multi-time frame analysis, this allows
you to analyze different time frames or
chart types.
So, meaning you could analyze
Uh well here show you you can what you
can analyze
second come up here. Come on ninja. Okay
so you can analyze tick volume range
second and minutebased charts. Okay
those are the ones you can analyze. So
if you're using something like a Reno,
you can't analyze the you can analyze
the Reno chart. If you got Ninja Reno or
something, you got to have tick replay
on. You just use chart. Okay. But you
can't analyze a different setting Reno
than your underlying chart. But you can
use it on a on a Reno chart.
All right. So
get back here. So if you want to analyze
the chart type you're trading for
example you want to see one minute
signals on your one minute chart you
just leave it at zero. If you want to
change it to a five minute you change it
to five uh minute and you change the
period value five. If you want a 30
minute chart change the period type to
minute and you put in period value as
30. Okay. Now tips level. This is the
most important setting that you're going
to use. Default is one.
range from 1 through six with one being
the minimum, six being the highest
setting. Rises gradually from one to
six. Setting of three is kind of
mid-range.
Low settings are good on slower markets.
Higher settings are more volatile
markets, but one is good for most
markets to start with. So if you start
with one and you say there's too many
signals, then you could adjust it up.
Remember three is sort of the mid
the mid level. Okay. Now swing filter
swing period. Obviously if you want to
be filtering out tipping points at swing
highs or swing lows, this is where you
would do it. Okay.
So you know five is a good setting. You
can use one, three, seven, nine. Really
depends on your trading style. Minimum
volume required.
Five is the default.
I don't think you really want to go
lower than five. Um, you want to have
something, you know, a minimum amount of
volume to trade to analyze. Okay?
Set it higher, for example, 10, 15, 20
for more volume. But, you know, when
you're in most markets like E- Minis, it
doesn't matter. You got good volume.
It's more for if you're trading in
thinner markets like
some of the agricultural products. Um,
yeah, you want going to want to have a
minimum volume setting. Even some of the
currencies that can be thin at times
like Swiss Frank,
you want to have a um minimum volume
setting. Okay? Again, you can set it as
high as you want, but I said for most
liquid markets, it doesn't matter that
much because they they just trade a lot
of volume anyway. Okay, so you're you're
pretty well set.
Momentum strength is another important
setting is default leave set to three.
So three is average momentum in the
market. to disable set to zero zero
momentum. we wouldn't look at momentum
one would be I say the weakest momentum
but it's really the the lowest the
minimum momentum requirement
um three is average six is strongest you
know two and four are available but I I
just tend to stick with one three and
six the maximum level of course is is
six now PC movement now this is a new
setting um on a lot of our indicators
but what it does is it looks for
PLC moving
between bars. Okay. And it's important
because basically what you have is
volume shifting up or down. Okay. And
why that's important is because you know
if volume is shifting
right then
price shifts together with volume that
gives strong signals right because you
know that that's uh DAO theory right
when when price is going up you want
volume to be increasing and if volume
not necessarily increasing but moving in
the direction of price yeah I I you're
just in a better position overall. Okay.
Now, you got a sound alert if you want
to use sound alert for signals. It's
disabled. I don't uh I'm not a big fan
of of sound alerts per se because,
you know, if you got a lot of indicators
running um and the market's moving
quickly and you got a lot of charts
open, you're going to get a lot of
sounds going off and it can be a little
confusing. So, those are the main
settings. Okay. So
just really quick, you know, again, you
know, you could adjust the settings
depending on the market you're trading,
you know, so this is um
tips level as three, momentum strength
of one. Um this is in the overnight
session
in the MEES, right? You see gives some
very good signals. I mean, it gives you
some little bearish signals here, but
then, you know, maybe you get stopped
out at a small loss, but then it gets
you right back in to catch the major
moves up, right? Tips levels three.
That's the average tip level. You want I
like a little bit of momentum strength.
That's why I set it at one. If you set
momentum strength higher, like say, you
know, six, you're going to find yourself
again, you know, there there's a
trade-off between tips level and
momentum strength level. um you know
three and three is also good but
generally speaking you know if you
really ramp up the momentum strength to
the highest level uh I mean yeah you'll
find strong trends but sometimes you're
going to find yourself you know getting
a trade at the high at a the highest
movement this is the same setting okay
crude oil again three and one tips level
three momentum strength one
okay again it It gave a bullish signal
here, a bullish signal here, but still
came right back with the bearish
signals, then the bullish signal back
up. Okay,
now this is with the RV chart, right?
This is I got momentum strength turned
off here, three zero, but it's still the
tips level of three, right? made some
nice moves down, nice moves up, nice
move down, you know, and this trade
doesn't work out right here, but goes
right back with the stunner right
afterwards. Um, is it E- mini RV chart?
Yeah, you know, I can do without this
trade here, these trades here, but I
could definitely live with this 40 point
selloff here from 6930 down to 68.90.
Even up here is a nice move up, nice
little move down. Um, you know, again,
tips level three, momentum strength
zero. Uh, you know, on a on an RV chart
or a Reno chart or something, I I tend
to turn off momentum strength or just
because it's, you know, it's a momentum
chart by itself. So, I I don't need to
try and get fancy and use momentum.
Now, here's where it gets interesting.
Okay, so this is um a eurourrency.
It's a one minute chart, but it's
plotting 15minute time frame signals.
Okay, so it's taking the the longer
view of the market and putting it on my
shorter time frame chart. Okay, so you
can see here minute is 15 and I'm just
using tips level one momentum strength
one.
Okay. So, in that gas, now this is using
a five minute chart. And again, you
know, you could hone in on what you
think is is a good chart, right? It
doesn't have to be five minutes, could
be three minutes, could be seven
minutes, 10 minutes.
But if I'm using a higher time frame
chart, I tend to keep tips level set at
one and momentum strength either off or
at one. I like to have just a little bit
of momentum, right? I don't like to
necessarily turn it off because I like
to try and ride with the trend, ride
with the movements. Especially if it's a
higher time frame chart,
I want to be going in that direction.
Now, this is bonds again with five
minute setting
multi-time frame analysis. Tips levels
one momentum strength is also one,
right? Catching the nice moves down
again. It tried to get long a little bit
here. tried to catch, you know, there
was a little bit of turn taking place in
there, but just wasn't to be just as
here. And it just keeps you short,
right? Same here. Nice move down, little
bullish signals that, you know, they go
up, then sort of stall out, but then the
bearish signals come back in
to catch the major move back down.
Crude oil, similar thing. Five minutes
tip level of one momentum strength at
one. Right? You see it's just catching
this beautiful move up
some short signals but it just reverses
keeps it back long again. Okay. Crude
oil. Now this is the actual underlying
chart with a higher tips level three.
Momentum strength is three also. So it's
again it's stronger tips level stronger
momentum strength.
Right? Catch this nice move, little move
down, nice move up.
There's some bearish order flow in here,
right? It's giving you signals, but you
know, this market is resilient.
Even though it gives them little, it
gives, you know, 1, two, three, four
cells. It can't sell off. And then it
reverses, reads the order flow
that there's something bullish taking
place. And, you know, it catches the
move back up and again back. catch a
little move down and a little move back
up again.
Uh where are we here? This is your
currency. Three and three. Same one as
the crude oil I just showed you. All
right. So flows tips levels at three.
Momentum strength at three. Again, I
like to trade with a little bit of
momentum. Whether you use one, three, or
six, it's up to you. I like to use at
least one. But if I'm
going to raise the tips level, say
three, right, it's going to be a little
bit more stricter. That's why I say, you
know, if you're using a tips level of
three and a momentum strength of say
six, um,
you might not catch that turn right
away, right? Simply because the momentum
hasn't shown up yet. So just keep that
in mind. So ultra bonds it's a one
minute chart off 5 minutes full tips
setting.
Okay. Crude oil three of three
again. You know this is
crude oil on the 5th. Go back here. This
was in the morning right? This is 2 in
the morning. 3 in the morning. 4 in the
morning.
This is the same day, but this is in the
f uh
US session. This time it's 9:00 in the
morning, 10:00 in the morning, 11 in the
morning,
right? Euro currency
down, back up 3 and 3. Same setting
crude oil that I'm using here on
Eurourrency.
Tips level of three, momentum strength
of three.
Okay. Now, with those tips, right,
you're trading pressure, not price.
And what do I mean by that? Well,
every bar is a struggle between buyers
and sellers, right? Flow tips, pinpoints
when the balance tips before price
reacts. You know, sometimes the balance
tips, but the price doesn't react. Okay?
And that's unfortunate, but that that's
trading, right? We wish that every
signal would be profitable, but really
it's a long game, right? There's going
to be some signals that work excellent.
There's going to be some signals that
struggle. Okay, now remember your setup
isn't broken. Your timing is right. Most
traders spot the pattern but miss the
moment. Close tips shows you exactly
when aggression aligns with your levels.
So you enter with conviction, not hope.
Volume matters, but only when it means
something, right? I mean a lot of
traders get mesmerized by big volume in
the market, right? But sometimes this
volume it doesn't matter, right? It's
not important. So you could forget noisy
volume. Flow tips zeros in on meaningful
transactions
and shifts the point of control or and
shifts in the point of control filtering
out the fake moves. Right? when that's
what I'm talking about that PC movement
filter by using that it takes the volume
that matters the most and uses it in its
analysis
and it filters out fake moves and
consolidations and highlighting real
momentum because if you're using the PC
filter
and the market's consolidating you're
not going to see any signals.
Smart money leaves clues if you know
where to look. Right. Flows tips tracks
how big players absorb pressure at key
price levels. When selling stalls
despite high volume, a squeeze is
brewing. When buying dries up, it's time
to fade or step aside. Okay?
So, you got to understand, all right,
how big players
act in the market, right? They're going
to absorb selling at important levels,
right? Whether it's at uh lows, right,
as we call that absorption, but if it's
at highs, we we call it um resistance.
One time frame isn't enough, right?
Built-in multi-time frame analysis flows
tips confirm signals cross time frames.
Five minute signals managed on a one
minute chart, for example, or 15 minutes
managed on a one minute chart
or even a 30 second chart, you I mean
it's you always hear about traders say
oh yeah I trade uh I use a top down
approach you know daily chart then 4
hour charts and hourly 30 minutes then I
execute on a one minute chart what if
you could take your 30 minute chart
analysis plotted on your one minute
chart and even your 15-minute analysis
you could actually put different
instances of
flows tips on your chart. So, if you
want to have 15 minute signals as well
as five minute and 10-minute signals,
you could load them up all together on
your chart. And I'll show you that.
Remember, data is useless without
action.
Flows tips is built for action, right?
It's not just pretty charts. If signal
doesn't result in a tick move within two
bars, it's ignored. No movement, no
trade. It's as simple as that. So, let's
uh take a look here. Pull up the chart.
Okay.
Uh,
do I have a bar chart here? So, flows
dips. Okay. I mean, I was showing you
here on All right. This is a footprint
chart, but
for ease of use here,
I'll show you on a simple E- mini,
right? One minute chart. You can see up
there.
Excuse me. Let me uh make this
crosshairs a little bit darker.
Okay. So, all right. Wow. 7,06.
We're selling off right now. Um,
let's take a look at this indicator
settings.
So, you see, right, it's a five minute
chart or sorry, it's a one minute chart.
It says here 1 minute, but I'm using
five minute signals. Okay. I had said
that you know if you want to look at
sort of other higher time frames you
could actually load them. What you do is
you just add another instance
um close tips close tips and you could
make you know a 15minute chart on here.
We'll just keep it at one and one
because that's what I'm using here one
and one.
But if you're going to use that
another if you're going to put another
instance say you want to have 15 minutes
together with five minute I would
suggest uh change the color you know
green maybe I don't know what other
color to use dark orange so green and
dark orange would be 15 minute signals
Okay,
close those tips. So you see five here.
Actually, I got one little difference. I
got minimum volume of five here. This
one I got 10, but I can make that five.
Just give it a second. It's calculating.
you know, those tips, you do need to use
tick replay, have that enabled um
on your chart. Now, again, you know, if
it's a market that's got a lot of data,
first time you load it, it could take uh
minute or two to come up, but once it's
on there, it's on there. Um, getting
back to just really quick, I just want
to talk about something here.
What was it here? I'm going to show you
guys in a second this PC filter. It's
it is kind of a momentum filter, but
more importantly, it's probably more on
a breakout filter than using the
momentum filter because obviously if if
PC is moving, the market's moving, but
more importantly,
the momentum is shifting. Okay, so I
I'll show you that in a second here when
I get back to my chart. Okay. So, here's
the chart. All right. So, you can see
blue is five minute and some of these,
you know, this color is kind of this
different color blue. Probably there's
signals are aligned. That's why it's
just like overdrawing. That's why it
says different color.
Um, you know, 5 minute 15 minute chart.
But, let me uh I'll pull up a crude real
quick here.
And I'm going to make one change here.
Give me a second.
What I'll do is just try and keep it a
little bit easier. Mr. 55 bucks.
Um, what I'm going to do is I'll move
these.
Change this one to four.
And that way you can see the cuz people
ask you know oh sometimes the the
signals align or not align.
So one's a 15minute.
So you see it's still calculating. So it
plotted already the five. I was plotting
the 15.
Oh no I did wrong.
Okay. So you can see here's the red and
blue is the five minutes.
Orange
is the 15 minutes.
If there's any green
is 15 minute. Okay. Now
I'll just remove these. Well, I'll just
go back to the normal chart zero.
I'll show you. Right.
Okay. So, we'll just make it here with a
normal chart.
Sort of the the defaults here. Yeah.
Change the colors. Um, took off the
wrong one, but let's make it back to I
like blue and red. Blue. It's always
blue is buy. Red is sell. Blue.
Red. Okay. So, you see there's a lot of
signals. Okay. It was set at one, which
is its lowest. Um, momentum strength is
zero. I'll set that back at zero. But
I'm going to turn on PLC movement. Okay.
It's going to clean up your chart more
because now it's looking for more
movement
in volume.
Okay.
And just look at this area where we were
going sideways here. I'll just blow this
up.
Okay. You see this trend? It's all down.
All right. signals are all down.
If I have moment uh PLC movement off
this area here, right, you're seeing
buys and sells a lot of signals. Okay,
you got buy in here. Okay, I'm not
interested in those. Right, the market
that's going sideways. I just want to
sort of catch a trend. Now PLC movement
at one is about as uh tight as you could
get
with PLC movement.
You could set it at, you know, three or
say five even
to really catch, you know, sort of
stronger breakouts.
Okay, here this move down, right? Got
this little move up,
right? These moves down
now. Excuse
me.
What we have here is called trade entry
signal. Okay, what that means is
for a trade for a signal, right? The
signal is actually the triangles. It's
not these lines being drawn out. Okay,
these lines being drawn out is is a zone
because people ask where would you place
your stop? I use these zones as stop
placements. Okay, but the down triangle
is the signal where to get short or
where to get long. Blue for longs, red
for shorts with my stop at these areas
up here, okay? Where the zone is being
drawn out. Now, again, you could always
adjust it based on, you know, how how
the market's moving. Now,
you'll notice there's some zones like
this one here, this one here, where
there's no
triangle that fires off telling me to
get long here or get short here. Okay?
And in this case, the market would have
stopped you out here. This market would
have stopped you out here. Why is that?
Because what we have is the trade entry
signal,
which means you see down here it's
enabled.
Trade price level in ticks is one. Trade
validity in bars is five. Meaning it's
got to move at least one tick beyond
the low of the signal bar where the zone
is drawn out from
one tick lower than that low. Somewhere
in the next five bars,
then your signal then you'll get your
down triangle. Just as for a bullish
signal,
right, it's got to move one tick above
the high of the signal bar over the
next, in this case, five bars cuz I got
it set at one and five. And it doesn't
even get any higher. So, there's no
follow- through order flow. That's why
there's no bullish signal formed here.
There's just the zone. So, there was the
order flow, but no um confirmation. So,
it's a confirmation tool. Cuz if I have
it disabled,
disable it here.
Right? You would have taken this trade
and lost. Taken this trade and lost. Or
sorry, it's this one here and lost. So
if imagine, right? Do you want to take
this trade and get stopped out? No. Do
you want to take this trade, get stopped
out? No. You want to take this trade and
get stopped out? No. All right. you've
just removed
three losing trades,
you know, even one up here, right? Where
it's not working in the sense of no
follow through.
And just, you know, imagine, you know,
when you look over your trading results
over the course of a year and you're
like, man, if I could have just taken
out
10% of my bad trades,
what a difference that would have made
to your trading results. So you see
here, no signal, right? You that's good.
You don't want to take that trade. Just
as here, no up triangle. You don't want
to take that trade. No down triangle
here. That's a losing trade you don't
want to take. Right? You just removed
one, two, three losing trades.
Okay.
So that's, you know, to me that's a good
thing, right? If you could remove some
of the trades that you would have lost
on, that's always a good idea. Um,
let's take a look here. So, we'll we'll
mess around with some of these settings.
So, three. So, we'll make this tips
level a little bit stronger. I'll keep
the trade entry signal turned on. Okay.
So, it's three. Momentum strength I got
turned off.
Okay. I mean, how's it look? It looks
decent. There's a lot of signals. I I
don't normally like so many signals.
you know, I could make the tips level
stronger. Six.
Okay. So, it's going to really look for
some strong tips levels. Um, you know,
when I'm looking at markets the first
time, I always want to watch and say,
you know, am I getting some decent
movements or not? You know, if there's
like a selloff like this, I want to
participate in it. So, tips level is
probably too strong. So,
um, I think it's better go back down to
three and use momentum strength. Okay. I
want momentum on my side. So, maybe I'll
make it three. Make it a little bit
stronger.
Three. So, now I'm starting to catch
this move down. Okay. The move down.
Move up. Um,
you know, you could even change, you
know, so you want to use three for the
uh time frame, 3 minutes.
You can see how it looks with test level
three,
momentum strength of three. Okay, so
you're still catching those moves down.
You know,
to me, that's the beauty of it is being
able to use this multi multiple multiple
sort of time frame analysis or the
higher time frame analysis on your lower
time frame chart. Um
because again, you know, sometimes the
more order flow you can have in your
analysis, the better. and specifically
to this tool flows tips
where it differs from some of the other
indicators that I've released is that
you know reading a bit more of the order
flow definitely helps at times
give you some stronger moves you know
bonds uh let's take a look at bonds here
getting what I got just a one minute
chart
I don't know. I haven't looked at bonds
today, but okay. So, from this morning,
3:00 a.m. here, this is a 3 minute.
Again, this is analyzing it off of what?
Whoops.
Excuse me. Off of a threeminut chart.
And again, you you're going to find when
you're using different settings,
you know, with three minute, you know,
if you're on sort of longer time frame
charts, you might want to lower the tips
level. This was this was on three. So,
you can see a buy one, two, three, four
buys. Okay. When I change it, still keep
it on the 3m minute, but I'm going to
lower tips levels down to one. Um,
momentum strength, I could keep at three
for now, but I'm just curious how it
looks. I may change it.
Okay. So, still the four. So, it's
really, you know, but there's a signal
not down there. Didn't come in. So,
maybe it's the typical level. I'll turn
the momentum strength level. Turn
momentum strength off.
All right. So, now I'm seeing a little
bit more movement, right? More signals.
I'm catching this high, catching this
low. If I wanted to,
yeah, I can see how it looks with swing
swing highs and swing lows. I would
enable the swing period.
Okay, so it's this is catching these
turning points here. All right,
this high, this low, this high, this
low,
this high. Okay, and you'll notice where
it comes back to. Okay, well, there's a
level here, but just blew through there
at 9:00. Um, but it rallied back up to
where? This previous level. Now it
rallies back up to where? This earlier
level.
Okay, this is ZB. I don't know. Try
ultra bonds. Got a little bit more
movement in ultra bonds than regular
bonds.
Okay. Again, this is with the swing
filter here, here, here. Um, you want to
use the swing filter. Turn that off. So,
you got just tips level of one.
Everything else is I mean, still got the
minimum volume, but that's fine. Trades
enough contracts, momentum strength off.
Okay. Okay. So you see obviously more
signals
you know and but you know it all comes
down to sort of refining and and finding
your sweet spot. Okay maybe you want to
have some PC movement
start at one right
and you know sometimes you people be
like ah I don't have any signals and
one it's because they got the tick
replay off. So to replay on your chart,
you got to make sure you have it turned
on. Sometimes people be like, "Oh, I
don't have any signals." And they'll
like, "Send me your settings." They'll
have swing filter turned on and they'll
have momentum strength turned on, right?
So they'll have like swing filter turned
on here and they'll have momentum
strength at six. Well, if you're using
momentum strength with a swing filter,
chances are you're not going to see
signals simply because they're working
against each other, right? Momentum
is for catching moves in a trend.
Whereas swing filter is for catching,
you know, highs and lows, swing highs
and swing lows. So, generally speaking,
you're not going to have momentum in at
a swing low. You will once you move away
from that low, but not at the not at the
swing low. Okay?
And you know you could even say you
don't want to use that you could just
use you know tips level of say three
and see how it uh this is just with tips
level of three. So you know it's
catching some nice moves up here. Nice
move down little move down a little move
up move up move back up.
Um, okay.
Let me take a look at a couple of
questions here.
Well, there there's question about crude
oil. Okay, let's take a look at crude.
Sean's asking show in crude. Now with
crude what do I got settings here?
This is 3 minutes.
Um
if I try momentum
one
momentum one let's try PC movement of
one.
Sam asked about QQQ. I don't I don't
have data on this machine PC for stocks
or or
QQQ. I just have futures data here.
So this is crude oil right now.
something way down here. Got a buy, came
down to your stop level, but you know,
gave a signal from this
5640 area, 50 point move
as it interesting question. Um,
he's got a lot of question. He's got
I've got several of your indicators.
Well, shift catalyst
scalper delta scalper.
Um, why do I need this one? Well, you
don't need it. I mean, I'll be honest
with you. It's for traders that are
trying to add another dimension to their
trading, right? It's like
having more than one car. Do you need
more than one car? No. Sometimes you
want to take out your Porsche for a
drive or something. It's, you know,
nowadays a lot of traders are using
execution systems like markers or blood
hound. And what they do is they just let
it run in the background. They don't
necessarily they just manage
they just manage their trading computer
making sure everything's running on all
cylinders to give them, you know, more
opportunities in the markets,
right? Really, that that's what it comes
down to. It's more than one way to look
at the market. I mean, that's what makes
the market is how everyone views the
market differently. If we all looked at
the market the same way,
the market wouldn't move. We'd all buy
at the same time, we'd all sell at the
same time, and price would be zero.
Okay?
Um,
and you know these these indicators,
they're all based on different aspects
of order flow, right? I mean, I I have
you guys know I I have this thing called
the toolbox, right? which is a a tool
that allows traders sort of piece
together their own
orderflow indicator
by using different aspects of order
flow. So like tools like this is even
more advanced than um something you
would cobble together using the toolbox.
Okay, but they don't read the same
things. It's pointless to have a
different indicator reading the same
things, right? It's completely
different. and delta sculpers reads
delta um catalyst reads something
different than what show hand reads.
Okay, so they they all read different
aspects of the order flow.
Gold. Well, gold is interesting because
gold has been crazy. Sally asks about
gold. Honestly, I haven't looked at gold
too much.
over the last couple days even though I
know this was partly I haven't looked at
gold because it's just uh going berserk
and it's been volatile honestly um you
know this is what was the setting that I
had this was the setting I had just used
on crude got PC movement it's on a
threeminut chart
but let's go back down to a regular
chart so it's got tips level of three
momentum strength one PLC movement of
one as well I see there's just one
signal there.
Okay. So, you know, buy here, buy here.
This sell didn't work out. Some buys in
there.
Now, gold, right? Problem with volatile
markets, excuse me, is,
you know, you're going to get movements
like this where it just drops down,
drops back up. Um, what I suggest for
some traders to try is going on, again,
it depends on what type of chart you're
using.
Yeah, you could look at very shorter
time frame, 30 second.
Excuse me, can I drink something?
Okay, here. Just giving some bearish
signals here. Bearish there.
Again, what I started, what I would do
if I'm looking at market from scratch is
I'd set the settings as low as possible.
Zero.
See how it looks. Okay. Again, I got 30
second on here. This is a one minute
chart, but just 30 second signals.
Okay.
This was the trend down in the morning,
but by US hours seemed to be decent. 40,
you know, 45
all the way up into
60s. These are big moves in gold.
You know, it moves up, move down,
sideways.
Right now, it's g some bearish signals
in there.
Um
RV stands for it's a type of chart. Um
RV is uh reversal bars. It's
it's not native to Ninja Trader. You can
find it in the ecosystem Ninja Trader
ecosystem.
Uh
and no, it's not included. If just go to
the Ninja Trader ecosystem, look up RV
bars and you'll find it in there. It's a
free bar
type. Um, I don't want to get into it
too much on this one. Curtis asks, "What
are the requirements needed for flow
flow tips?" We just need Ninja Trader 8.
It'll run on Ninja Trader 8. It's not
for No, no one uses seven anymore, but
uh that's it. You just got to have uh
tick replay on. That's it.
I mean, if you don't have tick replay
on, you'll see a popup. I believe says,
let's see if it comes up.
No, it doesn't come up. There is. Please
turn on tick replay in the data
settings. Okay.
I mean, the thing with tick replay is so
that you can see the historical plots.
Okay. You know, so take a look,
you know, since we're on gold, take a
look at well, silver.
Silver's got a lot of people's attention
obviously with uh the price
where it's at.
There a lot of guys crushing it in
silver market because there's very big
moves.
You just got to gold and silver right
now. If you're trading those markets,
you got to cut your losses quick. Don't
uh don't don't try to wait it out for it
to come back. You could catch some very
big moves up and down,
but uh it it's definitely a market that
you want to
manage your risk. any volatile market
kind of manage your risk. This is 30
seconds. Um
but again, you know, I haven't gone
through the settings for silver on
what's uh ideal,
but this is just basic basic settings.
Jimmy asks, is there a signal quality?
No. Um what's your difference between
signal quality during back testing and
tick replay versus market replay? Well,
tick replay. What it means is
there's there's two. If you're new to
Ninja Trader, market replay is where you
can download the data to your computer
and play it back. Tick replay.
If I don't have tick replay on, I'm not
going to see the signals, historical
signals. Okay? Like here, this this sell
or this buy. um it just won't show up
because what it's doing when
the way
say a a footprint chart works right like
this is a footprint chart
is
it reads the data on a tick by tick
basis. Okay. So, if you have tick replay
disabled, all this historical data will
not show up because it's not pulling in
that data and then formatting it onto
the footprint chart. It will start
recording it from the time I open my
chart, but I won't have the historical
part. And that's important because what
tips does is it reads this footprint
data as it's coming in on the footprint.
So it's doing footprint analysis,
but it's plotting it on the bar chart.
Okay? So you don't need a footprint
chart to do it. You just need the
the data as it comes in as it would be
plotted on a footprint chart. So that's
why you need the tick replay enabled.
That's what the tick replay does is it
handles the historical data to sort of
put it on the back end of the software
to do the analysis as it would on a
normal footprint chart, but it's just
plotting it on a bar chart. Okay.
Um let's see here.
Are your signals available as indicators
that can be used in another indicator or
trading strategy or is they visual only?
Um, I'm not sure exactly what you're
asking there, but it's well obviously
it's visual, but if you run something
like
markers,
okay, I know a lot of my users use
markers
from the indicator store. this one here,
right? To automate it. And it's
explained in the user guide, how to
automate
um
if I got the user guide open here. Uh
I don't have it open, but uh in the user
guide here, let me just
pull it up. All right. in this in the
user guide
explain here how to set it up
in markers. Okay.
Um let me see here.
Okay, I see your question. She song
about uh the other thing
she I'll email you directly on that
because it's it's not related here. But
um Jimmy G
strategy, you know, I I I don't use the
Ninja Trader um strategy builder. I use
unfortunately I use markers. I I just
found it years ago to be the best one
for me to use. That's why I never
migrated over to Strategy Builder.
All right, everybody. I'm going to end
it there. I've been on here for an hour.
I don't want to keep you guys on all
day. So, um, again, you know, if you're
interested, orderflows.comflowtip.
I'll put the link in the chat there just
so you guys have it, but you guys got
all the emails, but I'll throw it in the
chat. It's www.
https
orderflows.com/flows
tips. And again, you know, it's uh the
price that it's out now is is the lowest
it's going to be um after sort of this
launch period. It's just going to go
back into the stable and it's going to
be priced at a at a higher price. So,
you're saving about 200 bucks right now
on it.
So again, you just go to
orderflows.comflows
tips and thanks for coming out today
everyone. So, have a great rest of your
day and David, I'll get you sorted out
and uh same with you, Chi